After my recent video about Rhystic
Study, I got a lot of comments saying
one specific thing: What about Sol Ring?
Why is it that Rhystic Study should be
banned, but not this all-powerful fast
mana piece?
Bits and pieces of my answer to that
question are sitting around in plain
sight. As I mentioned in that video, the
reason to ban things is having a high
power level plus having a bothersome
play pattern, and I find the play
pattern of Sol Ring less bothersome than
that of Rhystic. Not a very high bar, I
know, but the ring has cleared it. I
also had a segment in a 30-minute
defense tutors I put out last year where
I discussed what causes cards to feel
problematic and why a very early game
threat like Sol Ring feels less
game-warping than other very powerful
cards that exist. Not un-game-warping,
but less game-warping.
Still, I think it's worth returning to
the question of Sol Ring and asking some
questions about it and giving the
question of whether it should stay legal
a fair shake. I still firmly lean on the
side of not banning it currently, and
I'll be laying out my reasons for
feeling that way, but the arguments in
favor of a ban are also fascinating, and
I love being fascinated. Sol Ring is a
card that can really jump-start an
aggressive game plan, and if you're
looking for other ways to get your speed
on, look no further than the red
collection from this video's sponsor,
Void Monster. voidmonster.org is a
TCG-inspired accessory and apparel shop
started by artist Forest Uml, and every
month there's a new drop featuring some
fantastic original designs that's only
available to pre-order for 1 week. This
week is the red collection, which
features a deck box, sleeves, a playmat,
and a card binder, all with variations
of this red pattern with these sort of
rocky magnet details that I really dig.
As always, these are some super cool
accessories available only for a limited
time, and if you're interested in them,
you should follow my link in the
description and pre-order by March 1st
at noon PST. Thanks to Void Monster for
sponsoring the video.
Okay, so we're going to start with the
play patterns of Sol Ring and why I find
them sometimes problematic, but
unobjectionable a lot of the rest of the
time. The card's most obvious feature is
that it warps early games. Turn one Sol
Ring, as well as its mean older brother,
turn one Sol Ring, or Arcane Signet, can
really set a player up for a nasty turn
two and turn three. I think most casual
EDH players have been flattened by a
killer Sol Ring roll out in their time,
but that earliness of Sol Ring is
actually a reason why I don't always
mind it so much. Turn one Sol Ring is
amazing. Turn two Sol Ring is also
pretty juicy, but what if you draw into
it on turn three? How about turn four or
five? At a certain point you might not
even want to draw into this little guy,
and that points to something important
about the card. It's ephemeral nature.
To briefly return to a metaphor I used
last year, Sol Ring is strongest when it
comes earliest in the pipeline toward
victory, but it falls off fast compared
to a lot of other especially powerful
cards. Smothering Tithe is another card
that offers a lot of mana for its cost,
but in that case the mana is dynamic in
how quickly it gets generated, it's
storable, and it since it's in the form
of treasures, it can also enable some
powerful artifact synergies. It's still
just mana, but it's a decidedly more
scalable and flexible form of mana. Next
up along the pipeline might be a
powerful draw engine like Rhystic Study
or The One Ring. A strong flow of cards
will almost always be useful, whether
that be in an early setup turn or for
when a player is drawing their way
toward a kill. The potency of one of
these could be limited by the amount of
mana a player has, but drawing cards can
also draw into ways to solve a player's
mana issues, so for most decks this will
be a temporary limitation, if even one
at all. Finally, we could talk about a
powerful end game card that will usually
spell out victory if a player is ahead,
and could give a shot at swinging the
game back around if they're behind.
Bolas's Citadel is a very powerful card,
and the point in a player's game plan
where it fits in is often quite far
along, just before a player is looking
to win.
All right, so what am I trying to say by
constructing this scale? Well, it's a
useful data point for analyzing cards
that most people would consider
powerful. Let's consider how often a
Bolas's Citadel will feel especially
powerful, maybe even too powerful for
some games. The answer to that might
vary a bit by table, but I'm willing to
bet it's reasonably frequent that this
card feels out of place. That's not any
sort of complaint about the card. I love
Bolas's Citadel, but it is an
interesting fact about it, and it's a
fact that has a lot to do with the point
in the game at which this card is
powerful. If a Bolas's Citadel hits the
table, the game will usually be over if
its controller is allowed to untap with
it, and it might even be over the same
turn it was played with the right setup.
This means that the social tools of the
EDH format, the fact that you have two
other opponents in the game basically,
aren't very useful at dealing with
Bolas's Citadel. If people happen to
have big boards right now and are able
to get an opportunity to swing big at
the Bolas's Citadel player, that could
be a good way of containing the card,
but it's kind of rare that your options
will be this good unless the Citadel
haver played it when they were pretty
far behind. More realistically, the
other players at the table will get
maybe a single turn cycle to either come
up with a piece of artifact removal or
have their own crazy pop off turn, and
if neither of those things happen,
you're kind of cooked. This stands in
contrast to the way things play out with
a card that is powerful earlier in the
game. A powerful draw engine like Braids
or Toski can generate a lot of card
advantage if not addressed, but these
are significantly more manageable
through the social nature of the format
since they won't be typically winning
the game super imminently. If somebody
is getting a lot of cards off of one of
these, their opponents can attack them
and or interact with some of their stuff
in order to slow them down. This is even
more true for a mana tool like Sol Ring
that comes into play early. It will
absolutely accelerate the game plan of
its caster, but in a bracket two or
three game, there will typically still
be a lot of turns for the table to work
together against the Sol Ringing player
before a win is threatened. To be clear,
this is not to say Sol Ring will never
be a problem. If the player who draws it
is playing the strongest deck, if that
player draws other powerful stuff in
conjunction with the ring, if one or
more of their opponents has a rough
start, all of these could result in Sol
Ring causing a blowout, turning an
uphill battle into a non-game. This
absolutely does happen sometimes, but
it's not the norm of the card in my
experience. More frequently, players do
get ample opportunity to gang up on the
Sol Ring player, and that's assuming
it's a problem at all. Many a player has
kept a questionable hand with a Sol Ring
in it, and in those cases, it's pretty
common to see a scary first three turns
followed by a rather un-concerning turns
four, five, and six.
>> [snorts]
>> Another factor that's worth considering
with regard to banning a card is how
much a card dominates the landscape of a
particular game it's in.
If the legends about Primeval Titan are
to be believed, it basically transformed
the Commander format into the Primeval
Titan format for a year or so, with
everybody playing it and stealing it and
copying it in order to get their
favorite lands out onto the board as
fast as possible. The same goes for
Prophet of Kruphix, instantly
transforming a game into a Prophet of
Kruphix game the second it hit the
field. This can even be the case for
Rhystic Study. A player getting to draw
a lot of extra cards might trivialize
any other set of value engines they were
playing, turning their game plan from
insert complex synergy web here into
Rhystic Study, end of story. In contrast
to these examples, Sol Ring is humble
and task-oriented. It enables a player's
game plan early on, but the card lacks
any sort of identity or scaling, so
after a few turns, it often slips into
the background. I've had multiple games
recently where I entirely forgot it had
been played, only remembering about it
after a moment of marveling at how sleek
and tuned an opponent's deck had seemed.
To be clear, this isn't necessarily a
perfect defense of a powerful card. You
could make similar arguments about Mana
Crypt and Jeweled Lotus, and I'm
perfectly happy with them staying
banned. Still, I do see some appeal in
the fact that this is a universally
available tool that can give players a
chance to play an accelerated version of
their game plan. To me, getting to be
the big bad is one of the defining
experiences of playing EDH, and it's an
experience that everybody deserves
access to. Now, just to be clear, I have
seen some bad defenses of Sol Ring that
argue that it's a tool of the people, an
equalizing factor between the stronger
players and the weaker players out
there, or the stronger decks and the
weaker decks.
These are bad defenses because anybody
can draw Sol Ring, including the
strongest player, and I prefer a
modified defense of the card that
focuses on its ability to increase early
game variance. Increased variance won't
necessarily create fairer games, nor is
fairness a particularly good metric for
analyzing Commander games in the first
place. But, what it can do is create
more balanced play experiences on the
aggregate, offering exciting games to
players playing decks that might
otherwise be slower. And, that's worth
something.
So, ultimately, I've grown a bit more
tolerant of Sol Ring over the past
couple years, even as I remain a fairly
variance averse player. Random power
spikes in a game plan can make for
frustratingly unpredictable play
experiences, making it impossible to
predict opposing decks and strategize. A
deck looking very different power-wise
game to game can also make it tricky to
set the table up for success, to find a
pairing of decks that will result in
something satisfying for everyone
involved. In principle, this logic could
provide a reason for me to hate Sol
Ring, but the profile of the card
manages to minimize some of the issues
that significant power level variance
can cause. Being strong early means it
is a thing that can be considered
strategically right from the outset of a
game, and this feature also offers
plenty of time for players to
collaborate in dealing with a Sol Ring
fueled game plan. Being a background
enabler whose presence in a game
diminishes over time does mitigate some
of the power spike it provides. A deck
that drew Sol Ring will usually feel
much faster, but it will still feel like
a version of itself, rather than a
mid-range deck that it's transformed
into a combo deck or something.
The biggest remaining issue I see with
Sol Ring is that sometimes the strongest
deck at the table will get it, and that
deck will then get to wipe the floor in
a way it might not have otherwise. This
undeniably does add to the difficulty in
constructing successful Commander games,
adds to the uncertainty of how much
power level difference between decks is
too much. Whether that fact overshadows
the other aspects of the card I brought
up is up to you.
All right, let's move on to the
logistics of banning Sol Ring. I wanted
to separate the theoretical case for
banning Sol Ring from the practical case
for banning it, in large part because I
find the practical case for banning Sol
Ring almost impossible to really
consider, an insurmountably challenging
proposition. It's been printed in every
single precon since 2011, and it's
played in over 80% of decks according to
EDHREC. Banning Sol Ring would be a
massive and monumental undertaking,
requiring a prolonged communication
campaign to reach all sectors of the
player base. I think we as EDH players
on the internet have a tendency to
assume the community as a whole is far
more cohesive and engaged than they
really are. Like surely these spicy
musings on Reddit or YouTube are an
accurate reflection of the player base.
But no, the EDH format is full of people
who don't consume much content about it,
who haven't heard the latest
announcement about the bracket system,
who don't pay much attention to current
sets, who don't spend a whole lot of
time building decks, and who don't get
together to play more than once a month,
if that.
Take a moment to think about it. For a
60-card format, the people playing it
competitively will be actively listening
for ban updates because that affects the
meta game and also seems to happen a lot
now. We can also think about the average
Commander player who ran Jeweled Lotus
or Mana Crypt or even the still legal
Mystic Study. These players will be
relatively in tune with the Commander
format compared to most players and will
be able to actively receive any news
about these cards getting banned.
Meanwhile, if Sol Ring was banned, the
median Sol Ring player would probably
hear about it 3 months later and go,
"Oh, why?
Okay, guess I have some swaps to make."
In addition to being challenging to
fully convey to the player base, banning
Sol Ring would also fundamentally muddy
all Wizards of the Coast communication
about the Commander format. Precons
serve as an example of what Commander
deck building looks like, the tools it
should use, the features it should have,
and on a fundamental level, how the
format works. To ban a card that WotC
has chosen to put in every precon would
destroy any sort of messaging
consistency about what the format means
and would make any future messaging
power significantly weaker. In this way,
I do think part of the discussion of a
Sol Ring ban is a sign of the times. A
lot of Commander players kind of want to
undermine WotC's relationship with the
Commander format, which feels weird to
say out loud, but I don't think the
people who feel that way would disagree
with that assessment. It is also,
admittedly, very funny to demand that
Hasbro does something as supremely
stupid as banning Sol Ring. And after
all the destructive profit-driven
decisions of the past few years, it's
hard to deny there might be a little
Schadenfreude in watching them try and
recover from that fumble.
But the angst that bubbles in the hearts
of us terminally online Commander
players isn't great as a genuine
justification for something like a Sol
Ring ban. In the real world, weighing a
ban unfortunately does need to involve
considering the impact of that ban in
practical terms in addition to
theoretical reasoning. In the case of
Sol Ring, on a theoretical level, I'm
relatively ambivalent about it. I see
the issues the card has and it's very
high power level, but I also see some
genuine reasons why people like it. So,
my feelings probably end up basically a
wash. When we consider the practical
consequences though, it's kind of just
an obvious non-starter. A card that has
been printed and handed to the casual
player base as much as Sol Ring would
have to be noxious to be worth going to
the trouble of banning. Utterly
miserable and pleasure destroying on
every possible level. And whatever
issues you may have with Sol Ring, they
probably don't rise to that level.
This does bring up a question though.
What exactly constitutes a good
practical reason not to ban a card?
Being extremely widely printed to
players who are on the most casual
fringes of a format seems like a pretty
good logistical reason not to ban a card
to me. But what about other things? How
far do practicality arguments extend?
One of these practical reasons to keep a
card unbanned might be popularity and my
reasoning around Sol Ring is arguably a
version of this. However, realistically
what I care about most heavily here is
inclusion in precons. If a card has
showed up in more than half of precons
that's ever released, I'm going to be a
little leery of banning it since it's
been purposefully put in the hands of a
lot of more casual players.
But what if it's just a card that a lot
of people happen to play? That could be
perfectly fine.
Cards do need to be some degree of
popular in the first place to be banned
worthy of the after all. We're not going
to ban something that has no presence
and therefore no impact. Another
practical consideration that sometimes
comes up is price. A card being
expensive is a reason not to ban it, so
the reasoning could go because banning
it will financially impact players and
game stores alike, destroying value for
no good reason. My problem with this
reason is extremely simple. It also
applies to reprints. Every price-based
argument for not banning something like
Mana Crypt or for not banning Rhystic
Study now also works as an argument to
not reprint these cards for fear of
tanking the price that way. And that's
kind of a problem, right? Most people
would consider it a good thing for
Wizards of the Coast to print more of
the cards people want to play with. You
could consider a ban somewhat optically
different than mass reprints. Like it's
seen as a somewhat more aggressive
maneuver by the player base, but that's
splitting hairs as far as I'm concerned.
The same price-based logic is getting
employed and it's not any sort of logic
that deserves to see the light of day.
A final practical reason worth
discussing is iconicness, how
symbolically relevant a card is on the
scale of the Commander format. In my
Rhystic Study video, I laid out why I
don't put a whole lot of salt in the
iconicness of a card. But at the same
time, I suspected that Rhystic Study
would stick around for at least a bit
longer on the back of its iconic status.
And the ban announcement four days later
confirmed that prediction. While the
card isn't quite as iconic as Sol Ring,
there is an undeniable pedigree there.
It's a card that was printed six years
before the formation of the Rules
Committee, a card whose strange design
made it dead on arrival in one-v-one
formats, but also offered it a chance at
new life in the four-player Commander
format. It's a card that's powerful,
that's widely played, and that draws
attention to itself by its very design.
None of these are bulletproof reasons
not to ban a card, and indeed I find
them inadequate as reasons to keep
Rhystic Study legal. But it's also not
hard to imagine why other people might
find them adequate. The question of
whether to ban Rhystic Study, along with
that of Sol Ring or any other card,
comes down to how problematic it is on a
play pattern level versus how
challenging and harmful a ban would be
on a practical level.
Ultimately, I wouldn't be surprised to
see a Rhystic Study ban a little ways
down the line, but that'll require the
theoretical reasons to ban it surpassing
the practical reasons not to ban it in
the minds of the community in general
and the Commander format panel in
specific.
I certainly have strong feelings about
those theoretical reasons, but my
feelings are not the consensus opinion.
Yet.
We can call that a work in progress, I
suppose.
Thanks for watching and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Did you know that you can click and drag
cards from category to category in
Archidekt? I always forget, but it's
very fun to do whenever I remember and
definitely helpful in making deck
building a little quicker. A link to all
of my decks is in the description.
Also supporting the channel is Dragon
Shield. If you're looking for durable
sleeves in a great range of different
colors, you can follow my affiliate link
down in the description for 5% off your
sleeve order.
Finally, thank you to my lovely
supporters on YouTube and Patreon. Some
of whom are on screen now. I'll probably
put together a bonus segment about why I
don't think game changing Sol Ring makes
sense sometime in the next couple days
and if you want access to that or my
back catalog of bonus videos, you can
sign up for my Patreon or for a YouTube
membership.